let's apply what we just learned by
opening up the mainactivity.java file
within our project we're going to take
this networking code snippet and move it
over to its own async task so it runs on
a background thread the task is going to
be defined within this fragment class
but speaking of which it's actually
still called placeholder fragment let's
do a little bit of refactoring now by
giving it a real name let's call it
forecastfragment and then you can update
it in other appropriate places as well
we can also move forecastfragment into
its own file that way the main activity
won't get so long and cumbersome within
forecastfragment
we should define a new inner class
called fetchweathertask
which extends from async tasks and then
you can move the networking code snippet
here after you make the changes and run
your app it should look something like
this there really should be no
difference except it doesn't crash now
in the next step we'll add code to
execute the tasks and later in the
lesson we'll do JSON parsing and
updating the UI in the meantime though
make these initial changes to your code